[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in March of 2018 I was given the
incredible opportunity to go to West
Africa specifically to Senegal and The
Gambia
and the reason I went there is because
as some of you know I'm a student of
religions and at the time I was working
on my master's thesis about Sufism and
in particular the Tejano Sufi
Brotherhood originally this video was
intended to be a documentary more like
the other one that we have on Norse
ancient Norse traditions but so I filmed
a lot in bogel and such things and was
supposed to interview a lot of my
informants but certain circumstances
appeared that made those interviews not
possible at the moment but I still felt
like the material that I gathered there
was so valuable and so I thought that
maybe I can be the one giving you the
context instead even though I usually
don't like speaking for someone else
[Music]
the titania is a Sufi order or tariqa
sometimes also referred to as
Brotherhood that was founded in the 18th
and early 19th century by a man named
Ahmed Al Thani who was born in North
African Algeria eventually the titania
spread to West Africa and grew larger
and larger especially in the end of the
19th century and early 20th century
where it eventually became the form of
Islam practiced by the majority of the
population in Senegal and The Gambia
[Music]
sufism in general in fact is uncommonly
popular and common in this region in
Senegal it is said that 92 percent of
the population is Muslim and 95% of
those 92 percent belonged to a Sufi
Brotherhood and there are four major
Sufi Brotherhood's in this region their
largest is the titania they're sort of
the meridia the Cod area and the lioness
I'm not sure I'm pronouncing that last
one correctly so I was studying
specifically the titania and I was doing
a lot of fieldwork here in Stockholm and
one group practicing that faith or
belonging to that order often visiting
them during their Saturday dhikr
sessions and so on
[Music]
and it was because of this that I was
given the offer by them to follow them
to West Africa in March on a pilgrimage
to a village in Senegal called Bogle now
this is a pilgrimage performed once a
year by this group both most of the
members of the group in Stockholm but
also to John is from all around the
world come to this one rather small
village in Senegal called Bogle to visit
and meet their Sheikh or a spiritual
leader called
Abdullah Campari and this man I'll refer
to him as body from now on he is
incredibly important for this group he
if you visit one of their homes in
Stockholm there is usually at least one
large poster of him in their home there
are small sort of cups that they sell
that sort of a during other on his face
it shares a lot of similarities with
other Sufi orders they have the same
basic practices like dhikr Vicar being a
meditation or invocation of God's names
[Music]
[Applause]
they also have this culture of the shake
the shake being a spiritual sort of
leader that that people follow and
there's this very essential aspect of
Sufism which is the relationship between
a spiritual leader a shake and about
student and this is central to the
practice you need a shaking and a leader
to guide you on the spiritual path and
this is no different than the teach anya
and the shakes in West Africa in fact
often called Mara boots have incredible
power sometimes even political power
over the the population there another
central aspect of Sufism which is also
prevalent in the titania is the Sierra
which is obviously the the central piece
of this this video CRI meaning basically
pilgrimage or visit to a grave or a
mother boot it is very common practice
to make a pilgrimage to the grave site
or shrine of a deceased the saints a
Sufi saint wali or Sheikh but the CRO
pilgrimage is not exclusive to shrines
or dead shakes or in Saints they can
also be performed to once there are
still living and the Sierra Bogle is an
example of this because in Bogle the
village there is no shrine there is no
dead Saint or grave of a Mara poet or
anything like that instead the goal of
the pilgrimage is sheikh abdul-rahman
bari who is still alive today and it
resides there for a large periods of the
year
[Music]
[Music]
so anyway after some preparations I left
Sweden on March 25th or 26th or
something like that and went straight to
sera Kunda in The Gambia where I met
some of my informants most of my
informants if I were from the Gambia and
lived in that city and so I got to spend
some time with them in their hometown
and The Gambia is a country that's
basically inside of Senegal so there is
Senegal at the coast of West Africa and
then the gamba is basically a river that
runs from the coast and in inland in
Senegal and so city Kunda is right on
the coast and right next to the capital
city of banja world and so we spent a
day or two in serra cuando me and my
informants and most of that time was
spent sort of them showing me around
before on the first day we rented a bus
to to travel into Senegal this
pilgrimage is is a big deal in the
region and so as we were traveling with
the bus we saw a lot of other large
buses with people who were going there
and they were sort of decorated with
images of different sheiks including
body and it would often say
alhamdulillah or Santayana which means
the same thing
praise be to God in Arabic and full of
which is the local language and so
eventually we reached the village of
bogel which was our destination for this
pilgrimage and and while this place was
certainly larger than a lot of the other
villages we had visited it was by no
means a city or any kind of large place
it was a village out in the middle of
nowhere in Senegal it's actually located
in the southern part of Senegal or well
south of the Gambia I should say I
originally thought it was in the north
but but you know since you can't fight
it so it's such a small place that you
can't even find on a map so I had to go
in to Google Maps and sort of find a
small mosque that was in the city in
order to
see that it was even there the village
has kind of a Main Street with sort of
stores placed on on the sides but most
of the village is made up of these
compounds that I described where people
live and eat and socialize and all of
these things when you're in the middle
of the city there is a incredibly large
and beautiful green mosque that's
clearly meant to be the centerpiece of
the entire village and sort of the
center of the religious lives where
people go to pray and all these things
[Music]
[Music]
the village of boggle is a very
beautiful place there's a lot of people
there especially during this pilgrimage
but in spite of me being obviously the
only white person in the entire village
I felt incredibly welcomed while I was
there there is this incredible sense of
community to the whole situation that
anytime you run into someone on the
street they'll say hello they'll say
Salam alaikum the Muslim greeting which
means peace be upon you and if someone
is eating you like you walk by a family
eating in their house they'll always
kind of invite you to come eat with them
so you always feel very welcomed
[Music]
the central aspect of this pilgrimage in
various ways is the sheikh abdul-rahman
body and so the entire pilgrimage is
kind of formed around him and all
activities in one way or another kind of
involved his presence one of the first
things people do when they come there is
that they visit him in his home and this
compound of his is always packed with
people and he requires a lot of security
personnel in fact because people are
sort of desperate to to get there
sometimes and in our case we were sort
of waiting for him for a while in his
living room together with a lot of other
people and eventually when he entered
there was this silence that came over
the room and everyone stood up and
wanted to say hello to him and then he
sat down in a chair and and everyone got
the opportunity in small groups to sit
with him and speak to him for a few
minutes and also pray with him and as I
and my group were given the opportunity
to speak to him he expressed gratitude
that we had made this long journey and
he said that it's important that you
have made this journey for the sake of
Islam and not for my sake because if it
was for my sake then I wouldn't have
deserved it he also said that a lot of
people come there to find God in him but
that he instead always finds God in them
[Music]
didn't trade for and with us and that
was kind of it but that's one of the
main tenants of this pilgrimage is
meeting the Sheikh and having an
opportunity to come in close contact
with him on Friday there's of course
also the Friday prayer and especially
during the Sierra Bogle a lot of people
come to participate in this pray people
from the surrounding villages as well as
tjanus like I said from all around the
world basically come here for this
pilgrimage and so the mosque on this
occasion was just as full as it could be
there were people even outside the
mosque they were praying because they
couldn't fit inside
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the shake also of course attends this
Friday prayer and every time he has to
leave his house or his compound and
steps out to sort of the streets he is
followed by an army of security
personnel because there is always a huge
group of people surrounding him that
sing vicar lillahi la la and tried to
get as close to him as possible or to
touch him to receive some of that Baraka
it's almost reminiscent of a rock star
or sort of the Beatles back in the 60s
it's got a similar feel to it
[Applause]
through the help from his security he
manages to get to the mosque into other
places and after the regular prayer led
by an imam not the sheikh by the way the
Sheikh then holds kind of a speech you
could say but he never really speaks
himself he has another person next to
him with a microphone so the Sheikh will
whisper to him and then this other man
will sort of paraphrase what he said the
Sheikh also then receives gifts like
money and things like that while he sits
there and then he reads from the Quran
or he recites the Quran and this he does
with his own voice this is kind of the
only time that he speaks himself is when
he prays or recites the Quran
[Music]
[Music]
Tamara DHIA and occupy I need man a new
high demoted in Muay Thai
most people in this village where what
could be considered ceremonial clothes
like cuffed on sand and they always
carry around the hospice or prayer beads
which they actually have one here one of
these that they carry around either
while praying or around their neck like
this and this is especially apparent
during the different specific rituals
like the friday prayer or later the same
day when they have a HUD that are
meeting in the middle of of the village
now--had there is a meeting where most
of the community gathers in one single
spot and they do dhikr vicky ode is one
of the most central and universal
practices within Sufism it is often
described as a kind of meditation where
the names of God are repeated over and
over again for long periods of time or
even more commonly the first part of the
Shahada the proclamation of faith
la ilaha illallah there is no god but
God is repeated over and over again in a
kind of singing fashion sometimes but
they can be performed in many different
ways some they would completely silently
other do is or do it very ecstatically
like including dancing and drums and
stuff and others are somewhere in
between the two janya have a very
melodic dhikr as you will see from these
clips that I'm showing you it's it's
almost got a kind of singing quality to
it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when there isn't any specific rituals or
ceremonies performed in the city people
socialize they walk around they meet old
friends and family a lot of people sit
in their compounds and they sort of
prepare food there are animals walking
around in the village freely often like
cows and goats and chickens and stuff
and so everyday people prepare food by
slaughtering a cow and then cooking it
and eating it the same day and things
like there's a very immediate kind of
feeling to it the last day of the
pilgrimage is the Saturday and this is
also the kind of main event the main day
of the pilgrimage a lot of people arrive
some days before but on the Saturday is
the day that everyone comes there that's
sort of the main event of the entire
thing and in the evening on Saturday
there is this ceremony a ritual or event
where politicians and military personnel
and generally just high-ranking
individuals from society in West Africa
come to this village to talk to the
Sheikh and so they are seated on this
platform in front of all the followers
and sheikh abdul-rahman body is praised
placed right in the middle and during
this events people first of all there is
a lot of spontaneous dhikr chants that
erupts in the audience and stuff but the
politicians and the Sheikh
they hold speeches and so they talk
about the relationship between politics
and Islam and things like that like they
spoke mostly in wolf or French so I
didn't really understand most of it so I
had to have it translated by my
informants later and what they told me
was that the Sheikh holds a speech to
all the politicians and to all the
guests that are there and he holds this
long speech about ethics and talks about
that they need to be kind to the people
they need to treat them with respect and
tolerance and kindness
and that the only reason they have
powers because of the people and so they
are not supposed to forget about the
people and this is a way I think or I
argue to reaffirm the relationship
between politics and religion or Islam
specifically to show that these
politicians and the politics of these
countries still adhere to those ethical
ideas of the religion which give them a
legitimacy if they show that they are
following the Sheikh and they listen to
his advice and affirm that relationship
with a religion that gives them
political legitimacy and this is a
continuation of a history in Senegal and
The Gambia that's that goes back over a
hundred years it was the same during
colonial times where the Mara boots are
Sheikh often acted as a mediator between
the colonial powers and the people and
even after independence the same was
true in a sense because the politicians
that the matter would always had a
strong relationship with each other so
for example if a sheikh hamad would
supported a political candidate that
dramatically increased his opportunity
to win the election so it's really
interesting to see how this still
prevails in a way and I argue that this
event where the politicians listen to
the speeches of the Sheikh it's a way to
reaffirm this relationship and to show
that these two aspects of society and
that is religion and politics are still
very much intertwined
even though Senegal and The Gambia both
consider themselves to be secularized
countries who have a secular democracy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Bogle is a very special place to these
people and in ask sort of a sacredness
to it as well not only the Sheikh
himself but the village I was talking to
one of the followers of this group while
I was there and I asked about things
like like smoking or drinking alcohol
and and music and stuff and he said that
well a lot of people here are smokers
but no one smokes in this village if
they feel like they have to smoke then
they have to step outside the village
limits and smoke outside and then come
back in which shows you again that the
city has a kind of sacredness to it and
as smoking and drinking is considered in
a negative light according to to most at
least Islamic doctrines there is this
tendency that you have to as academics
call it step outside of the ritual frame
or the sort of sacredness of the place
in order to do those things that are
considered inappropriate in a religious
setting like I said the same goes for
drinking alcohol and also to some degree
music it's not like music is forbidden
but it's generally avoided by most
people but then again sometimes in the
evenings as we were sitting outside the
house socializing someone would put on
some music on a phone or something like
that so it's not that strictly enforced
let's say
[Music]
[Music]
you may perhaps I've heard that Sufism
is characterized by asceticism and and
and and celibacy or stuff like that like
it's monks like Christian monks and this
isn't necessarily true there is a kind
of ascetic tradition within Sufism and
the Saints like body for example does
live a somewhat ascetic life but in no
way are they cut off from society
usually in most cases you are encouraged
to still partake in society and live
according to the Sunnah of the Prophet
than the Sharia
but there are some Sufi ideals that that
people like to adhere to that is
characteristically kind of ascetic for
example you're supposed to be prideful
but be very humble and not be too
attached to worldly things and and while
not all Sufis of course adhere to that
people like for example body at least
outwardly appear to do so not only are
almost miraculous stories told about him
that before he was born you couldn't
strike water but after he was you could
and that he has blessed this well in the
village that if you drink it it will
cure all your illnesses both mental and
and physical these very sort of magical
miraculous stories are told to to uplift
him to be very unique and in contact
with some other source the divine in
this case God and these stories are also
corroborated by some of those ideals in
how he lives now that he lives somewhat
aesthetically that he's very humble he
isn't directly involved or interested in
politics he gives away a lot of charity
and all the money he receives he gives
to others and things like this he he
maintains that idea of a Sufi saint and
furthermore during the different rituals
and stuff he is always seated on a
heightened platform about
of everyone else also to symbolically
and aesthetically show that he is unique
that he is different from other people
another example of this is that he like
I mentioned early he doesn't talk
himself he always has someone beside him
that he whispers to and then this person
paraphrase is what he says for the
microphone and there's another way of
asserting his uniqueness to setting
apart from people and for him to to have
this role as a charismatic authoritative
figure that is a mediator between God
and the common folk or God and his
followers
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's a lot of charity happening in
this village as well not only does like
I said the Sheikh gave away a lot of his
gifts or all of his gifts according to
his followers but the community itself
sort of partakes in a lot of charities
so for example in the morning they would
often slaughter a cow and then cook it
and make a lot of food from it and
everyone in the compound would eat that
food but also the food would be given
away to those in the village who didn't
have the ability to cook their own food
or didn't have the money so there was
this constant charity of giving away
food and welcoming people to eat with us
that was also a very prominent and
important aspect of this pilgrimage
which also added to that sense of
community and that sense of of being
welcomed and I'm very very sort of
peaceful and really beautiful place to
be in in a lot of ways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for a lot of the people coming there it
is a way to reaffirm an identity and a
way to come together as a group of
people once there you'll be struck by
the incredible kindness and warmth of
the people and how welcomed you'll feel
I have never really experienced anything
like it it didn't matter that I was
Swedish or that I'm Christian or any of
those things
I was made to feel like I was part of
the group like I belong there and that's
something that I think we can all learn
from it was an incredible experience I
was talking to my friend site while I
was there and I asked him how he felt
about being there and being on this
pilgrimage and he said he felt really
good especially to experience but real
Islam is and I asked him what he meant
by that but is what is real Islam and he
just said we'll look around you everyone
takes care of each other everyone is
nice to each other there are thousands
of people in this village but there is
not a single fight and not a single
crime nothing like that it is a
community made up of love and peace and
that is to him what Islam is all about
that is real Islam this of course is in
great contrast to what a lot of people
especially here in the West think Islam
is I don't need to even describe the
kind of images that we get of Islam and
the opinions people have al Islam and
it's really striking to see the
difference in opinion of those people
who actually live that tradition and
those who don't or maybe don't have any
experience with it without making any
claims about what Islam is or isn't
because I can't do that a religion like
Islam is an incredibly diverse
traditions of all kinds of different
expressions but what I can say is that
what I experienced while I was in Bogle
and what I experienced when visiting the
group in Stockholm even is that very
Islam that my friend cite was describing
I'm a great believer in the value of
meeting people and getting to know
people from other cultures and people
you may not agree with for example
there's a lot of political turmoil in
Europe and
with America and all around the world
today with a lot of far-right ideologies
making their way into politics and stuff
and I think personally if you want to
try to work against bigotry and work
against racism and all these very foul
things that are creeping into society
again you know information isn't gonna
cut it
you know you can't talk to someone who
has a certain idea about Islam and just
give them information and they will
believe you because they have very
strong beliefs already the only thing
that's really gonna change someone's
mind is if they interact with other
people if a person who is afraid of
Muslims or have negative opinions about
Muslims actually get to know a Muslim
person or a group of Muslims and talk to
them there's a lot bigger chance that
they will change their mind and simply
by trying to espouse counter-arguments
and information on them by doing so
you'll notice that in most cases people
are nice and people want to integrate
into society they want to be part of
society they want to respect the laws of
the country they live in and if your
opinion is solely based on information
about for example Islam simply from the
news or from the media then of course
you're gonna have a negative opinion
about it it's like if all you knew about
airplanes was based on the news you'd
think that every airplane crashes but if
you actually get to know people if you
meet people if you talk to people you'll
notice that the reality of the situation
is a lot more complex and often in
opposition to what you see in the news
and therefore I urge everyone whether
you're an Islamophobe
or from a far-right political party in
Sweden or in Europe or whatever or even
if you're not one of those people I urge
you to go and meet these people to go
and talk to people even though like I
said I can't say that Islamist this or
that that Islam is either peaceful or
violent because Islam is both those
things any religion can lead to violence
and any religion can lead to peace but
what I've experienced in bogel and what
I've experienced growing up with Muslim
friends meeting different Muslim groups
and people of different cultures in
general is that in most of the cases
and especially in this case in boggle
what I experienced is love and kindness
and peace and community and a
willingness to coexist peacefully with
each other whether they be from the same
culture or from another culture from the
same religion or from another religion
that is the reality that I experienced
and experienced while I was on this
pilgrimage and if everyone can have just
the slice of that same experience then I
think this world might become a better
place eventually so thank you and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you